MARTIN AGUINIS: Hey everyone.
I'm Martin Aguinis, and
this is Andrew Brogdon,
from the Flutter
team here at Google.
And we're launching a video
series about Flutter Widgets.
[BEEP]
What if we introduced
each other?
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah, sure.
MARTIN AGUINIS: OK.
So this is Andrew Brogdon.
ANDREW BROGDON: This
is Martin Aguinis.
MARTIN AGUINIS: Yes.
ANDREW BROGDON: Aguinis.
MARTIN AGUINIS: Like the beer.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yes.
MARTIN AGUINIS: Yeah.
And we're both at the
Flutter team here at Google,
and we're actually
about to launch
a video series about widgets.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah, so
there's a lot of widgets.
We're going to cover
some important ones--
InheritedWidgets,
Stateful widget,
Stateless widget, and Keys,
which are an ID for widgets.
MARTIN AGUINIS: That's right.
There's definitely going
to be a lot of surprises
in some of these videos as
well, so you should definitely
stay tuned to check it out.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]